Winchester Mystery House in San Jose
California is one of the most haunted
places in America
Winchester Mystery House is a incredibly
unique Victorian mansion created by
Sarah Winchester heiress to the
Winchester Repeating Arms fortune Sarah
Winchester had a series of unfortunate
things happened to her including the
death of her husband and daughter she
was a spiritualist and visited a medium
to try and understand why the medium
said well the gun the one the west
there's a lot of karma there so head
west and build a house to appease these
spirits she started construction in 1884
which didn't stop until the day she died
the house is a hundred and sixty room
Victorian mansion there's no master plan
there's a lot of strange attributes
there's forty staircases forty
fireplaces four elevators we have a
number of staircases that lead right to
the ceiling doors that open up into
nothing or it's just a wall the house is
known for its spirits who many people
believe are the ghosts of people who
worked at the house or even Sarah
herself a lot of our guests and
employees have had very strange things
happen to them in this house sometimes
it's just footsteps hearing a voice in
the life that flickers or sometimes it's
an actual full physical manifestation if
we haven't solved the mysteries in 93
years then I don't know if we ever will
just across the border from war-torn
Syria in a forgotten city is an
unexpected sight the hotel Palmyra
[Music]
this hotel is different than others
because time has washed away the walls
time has left us impact it is it is a
journey into the past so many people has
passed through this hotel this hotel has
been here since 1874 and this is why we
tried to keep it as it is the city of
velvet has changed of course it's
feeling the impact of the war on one
side of the borders but it's also
feeling the effects of economic
depression that's affecting the whole
country at one point there were no
visitors to speak of and that was very
difficult the hotel used to be a haven
for visitors because of the ancient
Roman ruins just outside its doors it is
a constant reminder of me of the
importance of Baalbek and this is
something that was not accidentally
built here if I wanted to describe the
view in front of me daily when I look
out of the window when I come to the
hotel I'd be speechless and generally
it's hard for me to be speechless the
smell of this hotel is carpets old walls
and rusty faucets but that makes you
smile and this is I think essentially
what memories are all about
the old personnel that has been here
since the 50s and some some of the 60s
have stayed with us because to them it's
home a lot of other wisdom may authority
over certain sahasrara fall idea
will the variable oh she out there
somewhere but after all so Marianne back
we do nation upon and this is the
feeling that keeps them going
even with tourism dwindling in this
region we've never closed the doors of
the hotel no one has a right to touch
hotel palmera except for time
[Music]
in the canals of Xochimilco to our south
of Mexico City is an island with a
tragic and disturbing past la isla de
las maracas or the island of the dolls
is home to more than 2,500 mutilated and
partially dismembered dolls America's
know Sonia's son propiedad de
meteorology lien he lo que hago en este
lugar is continued Arkansas historian
Rogelio Sanchez Santana is the current
caretaker of the island perpetuating his
family stewardship of this mysterious
place recollect Abba Monica's que la
protección Jackie lafitte la bikina
joven Paulista murió en su casa es de
spirito pnina's Osteria Penner il parle
en tableau finestra's Monica's can
quantify in Canada's enourmous aura
Aaron Palace protección las unicast on
Coloradas en los árboles in al embrace
come attended arrows algunas NLP so what
Rasmus is done in de Gama second loss of
a hotel Julien sombrero Julianne Santana
died in 2001 and it is said that he
drowned the same way the young touristed
people believe that the spirits that
haunt the island belonged to who Leon or
the young girl or even the dolls
themselves Nance will feel the spiritus
widows extraneous karaoke no no puedo
entender whether you believe in spirits
or not a visit to this island will
surely haunt you
well after you've left
you
you
off the east coast of China near
Shanghai sits an archipelago of nearly
400 islands one of them is Zhongshan
Island a place where nature has
reclaimed what was once a thriving
fishing village
residents started leaving in the early
90s in search of areas where access to
mainland ports would be easier for
business and now lush greenery has taken
over the abandoned village
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in Guanajuato Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with mummies
[Music]
mi nombre es palomero vez la que yo yo
le directeur Adele museo de las mamiya's
de guanajuato el museo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un presentó sagrado kxe
hay una collection pneumonias Naturalis
with 117 bodies in total the museum has
the largest collection of natural
mummies in the world the mummies are the
well-preserved remains of people who
died during a cholera outbreak in Mexico
in the 1800s the museum is a haunting
and eerie experience for visitors an
opportunity to stare death in the face
Vienna was Kara's experiencia intima sa
encuentro Mistico con la muerte que
propecia reflection enter no a la
intención so prope vida yes NGO de la
misma es importante que las personas no
tengan miedo la muerte yell contrary oh
no bonobo phenomena natural como una
transición inevitable days existential
porque finalmente SE ma encontrar con
ella
opened in 1962 the TWA terminal also
known as t5 embodied the spirit of the
Golden Age of flying it was closed to
the public in 2001 and now sits
abandoned at one of the busiest hubs in
the world New York's John F Kennedy
Airport
[Music]
Japan's Hashima island has a foreboding
presence you might recognize it this
completely uninhabited island played
home to the villain in James Bond
Skyfall once a booming coal mining
operation that ended in the 1970s access
is strictly limited but coming here is
like stepping into a time capsule
[Music]
[Music]